au deuxième jour de sa visite en chine
lionel jospin est allé à la rencontre du
président ian fleming qui inspectait les
zones les plus touchées par les
inondations il fut question des droits
de l'homme ce qui n'a pas empêché les
entrepreneurs français d'obtenir la
promesse d'un contrat pour le métro de
shanghai au québec les narcos nord
enfin ils se sont vu le président
chinois et le premier ministre france un
président chinois qui d'ailleurs fait
tout pour ressembler physiquement à mao
les deux hommes auraient dû se
rencontrent à pékin mais le président
tianming en a décidé autrement il était
officiellement en tournée d'inspection
en province en raison des inondations
lionel jospin n'en a pas pris ombrage on
a parlé de la crise asiatique mais aussi
des droits de l'homme je lui ai dit
qu'il me semblait que le développement
économique
social
éducatif de la chine ferait que cette
volonté
d'affirmation des libertés et les droits
de l'homme ne viendrait plus grande même
si j'étais conscient que ce serait un
processus continu moment de détente à
shanghai la venue du célèbre moult
shanghai la plus grande ville de chine
la plus ouverte à l'économie de marché
d'ailleurs ici le français alstom a
signé une lettre d'intention pour
l'équipement du métro de la ville soit
un contrat de plus d'un milliard de
francs autre décision mais cette fois il
s'agit d'un geste humanitaire la france
a décidé d'aider les victimes des
inondations ces inondations qui touchent
actuellement la chine sont devenues un
enjeu politique il n'est pas impossible
que le régime en exagère l'ampleur car
toute cette affaire permet à l'armée de
redorer son blason et au régime de
reprendre les choses en main